hi guys welcome back to the very last
evan and katelyn podcast episode
[Music]
you're really going to make them wait
through the intro to say of the year
[Music]
no no we're going to keep on going we're
going to keep on going um but today's
podcast we're going to be looking
back at the year that was 2020
i don't think that it was the 2020 that
any of us ever imagined
at the beginning nope no
we're gonna be looking back at um our
predictions that we made
at the on the very first podcast of 2020
we're going to be looking back at how
well we thought we dealt
with all of the unexpected bumps we're
probably going to stay clear of
2020 in general and mainly just talk
about the two of us
how we dealt with it as people as a
couple
and as a business yeah yeah yeah but
first
we have some what's news because we've
been dealing with something
for the past month or so
guys we have rodents in our garage
they are above us while we are filming
they are above us
while we are streaming they are above us
while caitlyn
is sewing cursed cats
made of jeans yes it has been literally
haunting us
and and plaguing us for a while and we
have
it's a little bit of a story whole thing
it's been a whole
whole thing and every time we bring it
up to like you know a relative or this
or that they're like oh you put traps in
there i i
had mice once and you know after a few
days taken care of
yeah no it's been four weeks guys
the whole rodent story starts actually
with bees
we had bees a year and a half ago like
two years ago two years ago
in our garage attic yeah we hired people
to remove the bees and we thought that
they were done
but what the people actually did is they
sprayed like a dust up there that
that killed the bees and these were
killer bees not honeybees
yeah they they and i guess maybe that's
standard i'm not sure i thought that
they were removing them i thought they
were moving
steered clear because beerus well yeah
well killer bees specifically like they
are very aggressive
so we were like inside anyways we
thought that they were removed we
thought they removed the comb
turns out they they didn't
um and so for these past
several weeks we we started hearing
scratching
above the the garage attic we we have
like some
you know bug pest control people that
come and just do regular whatever
stuff at our house um we told them about
it because they also do rodent stuff
they like
you know recommended all these various
things we tried like a spray
like a natural spray that like makes
them want to go away like a little sound
thing you plug into the wall that does
like little ultrasonic
some kind of noise that they don't like
so we've been ramping up
like all of the steps that you'd usually
do but they are so
like persistent they're always there
always scratching
and they're so gutsy too they like ate
through the drywall and then they poke
their heads out
and they like watch us work it sounds
like a cartoon and when we would tell
the pest control people we've had
various
various companies and we'll get to where
the bees tie in in a second
but when we tell people they're like oh
you know they're you're
you're probably not going to hear them
during the day like you're never going
to see them
we're like no he looks at us he stares
at us we're down there using power tools
and he's up there screaming watching
photos he doesn't give a [ __ ] and
videos of there's at least one mouse who
just loves like
he's a little bit of a ham yeah he's you
know yeah
he loves to be on camera we have
like multiple videos of this guy
just poking his head out and looking at
us and we're like um hello we're trying
to film
and as we try to deal with it the hole
in our garage has been getting larger
and larger and larger as we try to like
you know deal with what ended up well
well yeah okay
so we'll get back to the bees yeah i
think so everyone was confused about
like
um you know why you know we would set
out like peanut butter and this and that
and like why they weren't going for it
um apparently it's because they were
eating
all the dead well the the the v
related stuff up there like bees and
honeycomb
and stuff well there's a lot of
conflicting theories that like the
people have had some people say that
they aren't
getting sustenance from from the beehive
and some people are saying they just
like
that area because the bees kind of
insulated it
insulated it or like made it cozy for
them or something
yeah okay but for whatever reason
because there was
a huge beehive in this corner of our
attic
still up there the mice were just
hanging out
chewing on it chewing on the drywall um
again
i think it's only one maybe two mice
from what we can
hear but like they
just really did not want to leave and
the whole
the hole in our garage ceiling has
gotten progressively bigger first it was
like what they chewed through
and then like we couldn't really see
what was going on so we had to like
drill a hole and we bought like a little
laparoscopic camera and stuff
to put it up there and then you know
when we had
um that's when we some beehive fell out
of the hole and we were like
oh there's beehive up here so then we
had b people come to remove the beehive
you know and then so then there was like
a two foot by two foot hole in the wall
and now there's
two two foot well i guess one now
there's a two
by two foot hole in the wall and a two
by two foot hole on this
like well on the ceiling and on the wall
adjacent to the ceiling anyways it's
we just wanted to share this story with
you guys because like we we like
we like sharing our life with you guys
you know and and it's just like
this has been such a strangely large
part of our life for the past
month and a half or so because i've got
you know we've gone to
the hardware store made the trip outside
to like
pick up supplies to deal with it ourself
probably like
five times various trips various
ways we've tried to do things we've had
probably about eight visits
from professionals people different
people dealing with different
sides of this and unbeknownst to you
guys
they have been part of at least three
live streams and
two videos yep they've been there
scratching i wonder if you like enhanced
the audio
at a party can you hear the little
switches because they're like
they're literally just scratching up
there and like chewing on stuff
the whole time they've definitely been
like i think we cut them from the video
but there have been parts where like
we're doing something um hello
yeah yeah they have been parts where we
cut it out
but yeah that's why in the um cat bed
made of jeans video
we like mentioned the bee lady and i had
to add a note
to the video in the end because i was
like that's not going to make any sense
at all but it was because they were
coming to remove the hive
yeah in the attic anyways
and i think it's been like a huge thing
i think we can we can finally tell the
story because we have
been sealing our attic i've been getting
up on the ladders and like sealing all
around the roof and feeling like
because our fat house had foundation
issues so there's all these entry points
and we've been
you know copper meshing all around the
house and and we've been doing
all these things sealing it all up we
removed
all the bees and we moved there's like
an area where they
kind of built a nest off yeah we removed
it we treated it and i think
that like i'm knocking on what i'm just
hoping we haven't heard
that i'm hoping so much we haven't heard
the mouse in like a week
yeah or so and we never saw that no we
never caught
anything in a trap they're just wily so
so not having heard him
either means that he left like after we
we dug out his nest and like cut the two
huge holes in the drywall either he was
like
no i don't like this house anymore or
he's in a different part of our attic
where he can hide even better and we
don't hear him
hopefully you guys never hear any
updates on the story and this is the end
please pray for us moving on to another
topic because that's like
don't think about it um moving on to
another topic
um another thing that we've been working
on in the background which has been
pretty fun
is our discord do you guys know what a
discord is
we did it when we started it we didn't
we knew what it was but we didn't really
know how we would use it
yeah we were kind of asked by the
especially the gaming community to make
a discord because i think
discords are really big in the gaming
community
and at first i didn't really know what
what it'd be used for and and how it
would use it but
now that we have a discord and we've
been utilizing it it's really great i
totally see the point of it
now and i think it's just a really
interesting tool that you can like
shape to your own needs but basically
discord is a like uh
like a hub of various chat rooms kind of
that you set yourself
so like for ours there's like diy
channels yeah it's kind of like what the
different you know
quote-unquote rooms are called yeah um
diy like different
gaming ones for the different games we
play we have like a pet's channel where
people share
pictures of their pets and it's very
cute we have like a fan art channel
yeah like all these different things
it's very fun it's really fun it's
basically just a place for
a lot of people who enjoy evan and
katelyn universe content
to come together and chat and share what
they're doing behind the scenes and
comment about like we pop in sometimes
and um you know we we just went through
a revamped shout out to our discord mods
yeah discord mods thank you guys
yeah we've revamped all the rules and
we've brought more mods on and we've
we've kind of like
upgraded it to the next level so so
that's another thing that we've been
working on behind the scenes
putting a lot of time and effort into um
that that not everyone knows about so we
thought we'd share it here yeah because
it's a really cool
are you ready to move on to our topic
now we've kind of talked about what's
been going on yes all right guys time
for
2020 in review um
how about first let's look back at what
we wrote down
in episode 50 for what our resolutions
for
2020 would be yes that that is the
episode that went live at the very
beginning of 2020
and we talked about our resolution so
let's see we
we split it into work and personal
resolutions i think we can go through
them
and see how we did i'm looking at the
first one the first work resolution
is balance bringing balance into our
life caitlin
work life balance caitlyn how do you
think we did uh are we gonna grade it
like out of ten
one no i think
i think we did like three or four three
or four so
definitely in the failing range failing
but like better than one
better than one so i will say well you
know we've we've kind of gone up and
down on balance we went we have had
periods of time
this year where we like would stop
working at like nine
read or play video games that was like
august
yeah there was like a couple different
periods where we have like a month at a
time yeah we just
dry in august where we're better and
like i know that sounds like not much
but for us that was really big to just
like take some time off in the evenings
yeah you know um we have in
a way brought well this isn't really
work life balance but it's a little bit
more balanced to the work that we do
because
uh like we do more gaming than we used
to and we've done
a little bit less on the main channel
yeah now i think in terms of like
broadening our horizons in a lot of ways
we did a lot of great stuff
in 2020 we did we i i i think i'll we'll
get to that later well yeah
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about about one goal at a time
did we hit balance
no i would say three or four out of ten
yeah i i think like the balance we were
talking about is work life balance and
we did not
accomplish that no a little progress
we i i read like three books oh was that
in 20
did that start in 2020 or no more books
like six bucks
okay okay i think i'm pretty sure that
was all twenty maybe a four maybe a four
out of ten
yeah there were moments where where
progress was made and then would
backslide for one reason or another yeah
another another thing that we had down
as a 2020 goal is more series in
but when we wrote that down we already
had virus diy
have we created more series so we had
bioverse diy and we had
just started like diyeri's
which was basically like not really a
new series
it was just putting all of our like
home makeover projects under a series
name
but then we kind of stopped doing those
yeah a little bit i think that we didn't
do much on the moore series but i think
but then oh no no which one cooking with
evan and caitlin that was
serious
you know it wasn't the most successful
no but you know we ventured out in in
the the materials that we oh yeah
another one
we did two uh makers test diy life hacks
oh yeah
that's kind of a series like i that was
definitely a big series that we did on
tick tock
oh yeah yeah because because like you
know each one of those
is each life hack is its own tick tock
tick tock
that was like a big thing that's true um
so how would you grade us
out of ten now i think that i'm going to
add some nuance to this
i think one of the reason why we wanted
more series
is so that we could
uh i have an answer help with the work
life balance sometimes and
and help with like the like big burden
of coming up with ideas and
and push our our our channel in new
directions
and i think that in a way that that was
the intent behind the more series if i'm
remembering it right
and i think that we accomplished those
goals but in different ways
yeah we did like you know like the
candle making we tried candle making we
tried various other
um video ideas
and i think that we pushed the channel
in in the
direction that we wanted but not by
using series by like
doing individual videos that pushed our
channel in the direction
sort of you're speaking very vague terms
so i'm not sure if that's going to like
come across
yeah the two of us know what i'm saying
yeah i know i know what you're saying
um but i think in terms of doing series
yeah
i would say four out of ten also
we did do some but we didn't like yeah
we didn't really push it
we didn't i think the biggest push was
like ian k cooking which we still might
do some more of
you know we're kind of taking we've
taken maybe we'll do eating cookies
cooking live
that could be fun that could be fun
we're not committing to anything no i
don't know no no we're not committing
okay next up on the list is pushing the
boundaries of the content of our channel
farther
i think this is what you said like more
science adjacent question mark
no but i think that we really did push
the boundaries of our content
um even further and i think that that
i i'm going to give us a 8 out of 10.
yeah i was going to say like a like a 9
out of ten
like like we just made we just made a
cat better out of jeans
knowing our intention when we made that
goal it wasn't that we wanted
to like oh all of a sudden we're gonna
start doing
uh travel vlogs it was pushing our
content
farther like within
things that still kind of made sense for
us um and i think we did like a nine out
of ten on that and even went a little
farther beyond because
again i'll use the cooking with evan and
caitlyn that was like a little bit that
was a big
farther beyond what i would have
expected but also like even even i think
the diy transparent screen it's like
yeah
that and the um underwater stream are
both like technology builds we hadn't
really done technology-based builds
we did do more science adjacent because
we did
um you know and when i say that i mean
like videos that
the whole thing was kind of science
adjacent like the pumpkin videos the
resin rainbows even like the cheese
which was cooking was also very science
adjacent
yeah like i feel like yeah and
this is um i'm like looking through
the toast coasters yeah you know a lot
of things we did do
and then we also tried i we also did
like what was the first
curse thing that we made in 2022 the uh
the first conclusion
was the mood ring toilets yeah so we
started we tried making cursed builds
again also the jeans that just came out
we also tried a couple like i don't
really know how to describe this other
than like
youtubery things like mixing all of our
pigments together
that's like a youtubery type of trend
but also
and like testing life hacks like five
minute crafts life hacks that's just
a youtubery trend like just more
experimental like you know
where the video is an experiment it's
like what's gonna happen
we don't know let's find out together
yeah
yeah and more of like it's just about
the experiment and not like
do an experiment and then do a build
based on that experiment right away
yeah which is more of what we used to do
yeah so i'd say like i'd say like nine
out of ten
maybe ten out of ten like i'm pretty
proud of um
the expansion we've done on the video
types and the last on the list for work
resolutions
spend more time on ideas i i think like
again nine or 10. yeah yeah nine or ten
out of ten
i give us like an a definitely for that
we
we behind the scenes we spend days
brainstorming ideas we're much more
conscious about like
what videos we're gonna do and why we're
doing them
i also think it's interesting i mean we
were just reflecting on this
when was the last time we brainstormed
two days ago three days ago
we were just reflecting on this we put
so many ideas down
on like our master idea list and then
later on we look at them and say
why were we so excited about that i
think interestingly like
dumping all our ideas out and then
re-looking at them
later really helps bring perspective on
whether that idea was something that we
just had excitement for in the moment
verse if it's like a really like
an idea that really idea yeah stands the
test of time in a way
and i think that that in our past when
we were just go and go and going
we just kind of had to like i'm not
going to say compromise but we just had
an idea and then we just went for it
because we had to go
well also right then if you think about
how we used to film videos
um we would publish
the video on friday on saturday
or sunday we would start filming the
video for the next friday
yeah and we'd work on it a few days and
we'd rush rush rush and then it would go
live friday and then we'd figure out the
next one
on that you know that weekend and it was
just like a never-ending cycle of
that um now that we have a little bit
more time
in between videos um we're
not as much on the never-ending
treadmill like we're not stumbling as
much on that treadmill we're still on
the treadmill yeah we're not stumbling
as much
but we're just trying to put more time
into it able to like you know there's a
few
uh videos that like you know might
might surprise people that we took a
long time on them like the wood
and resin computer we started that idea
probably four or five months before
we actually published it yeah you know
you know figuring out the idea and
working back and forth on design and
you know setting up the partnerships and
all of that um
resin pumpkin idea is something we had
for almost a year because we thought
about it like
i think around last halloween but there
wasn't enough time to let the experiment
run because it had to
run for you know as many days as the
pumpkins would last yeah so the
um the resin pumpkin you know video we
filmed like probably two other videos
or two or three other videos while we
were filming the resin pumpkin
you know there's there's an idea that um
we want to make coming up
um that's been on our list you know that
was the one yeah
like it's been on our list for how long
probably at least six months six months
or i think almost maybe almost a year
maybe a year
we've wanted to do it but we we know
it's going to take a lot of time
also we need to figure out a lot of
logistical elements to it
and i think that also as we grow as kind
of makers
and experiment with different materials
and all of that stuff
making contacts at various companies i
need to keep things vague because i
wanted to be a surprise for you guys
but like now that idea seems doable now
we just need like
three weeks to like pull it off right
yeah so so we want to get ahead on these
videos so we can
tackle some of these bigger things but i
think we have successfully
we do spend more time on the ideas i
think that's an a or a
plus yeah a or a plus yeah nine or ten
out of ten
yeah i would say i would say two now the
personal resolutions that we made at the
beginning of 2020
work out i'm looking over at our little
calendar
our our everyday account really good in
august would be great in august that's
also when we had time to read and stuff
okay in september october started to
slip
november we worked out like three times
december is a total fail december is
nothing
literally nowhere in december it's just
gotten progressively worse i think that
i think that as we get our like you know
you know work uh you know manage a
little bit more and although yeah i mean
i think we'll pick it back up but we
still degrade ourselves and we didn't
even start working out until like august
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna give us like
a three i'll give us a three two
three out of ten it's something though
you know maybe something
maybe even though we didn't you know you
would think five would be like working
out half the year
yeah i might upgrade this to a five
because getting started
working out hard more we worked out more
in 2020 we did that
10 out of 10. no that there's an
improvement there
it's not as much as i want i'll upgrade
us to a five five from a three okay
all right next up on the list is more
time to think and come up with what we
want to do
for like personal in our personal life
not really okay yeah
i think that like you know like the the
the
end result of make more time to to think
and come up with what we want to do
you know we we we started trying to
implement one day off per month
we like take the day off and we've done
that a few times
we've only literally only done it on our
birthdays
maybe one other day no no just our
birthdays we've done it twice hey
remember that one day
where we were like working and we wanted
to organize
and we're like ah let's throw in our
schedule and let's just go to ikea and
let's organize and that's like
okay three days you know
i don't know that's not i wouldn't say
that's i'm not really sure what we were
talking about in the personal resolution
of make more time to think and come up
with what we want to do
and non non-work well i think that i
think that
i might have written that scenario does
it make sense to your brain i think it
is it's like
when we because like i think that it's
really easy for us to default into
working
it's we we enjoy it we get a lot of joy
out of it like we know that you guys
enjoy and we're going to talk about
streaming later on
and i think that it's been really fun
like kicking off streaming more
figuring out what we like to stream
figuring out what you guys
enjoy for us to stream and all of that
and that's been like
a great thing but like since we have all
of these things
that are instantly rewarding that we
want to do
you know and that's that's good for the
business and everything it's so easy to
stay
incredibly busy but when we take time
off of work
every time i think that we've like
stopped working
for an extended period of time we have
had like
good revelations about like what we want
in our life what we want
like in our future and what we like want
like even like you know like when we
took time off for my birthday
we realized that we want to completely
change our entire system for storage
you know and like how like we we like
that's like such a weird small
miscellaneous thing but um yeah it's
just
uh it's just interesting because like i
think that whenever we do stop working
for long enough for us to stop thinking
about work
we think about other things and good
things come from that
we did design our future potential dream
house
yeah that took some thinking about it it
was a stream
so it was
so how would you grade us i would say
three out of ten maybe four out of ten
maybe five out of ten
because again like five out of ten it's
like make more time
we have tried to be more conscious about
like what we want in life and not just
work
yeah yeah and we did take more time off
we did in 2020. we still have a lot of
room to improve
but i think we did okay okay related to
what you're just saying
next personal resolution was tackle the
junk room and set up systems to minimize
i hadn't read that i copied and pasted
this but i hadn't read it we did okay
we did okay we did better i'd say
six or seven or eight no no six
six six we bought some shelves
[Laughter]
they're great and we made some decisions
we made some decisions
yeah we haven't implemented them all a
lot of it's still in our brains
yeah and a lot of it isn't really stuff
that you guys will see
but like you know getting our life in
order a little bit
and remember for there was a period of
time where we had essentially three junk
rooms
yeah the garage was a junk room in a lot
of ways
the entryway was when was the garage and
the
um guest room was a junk room at one
point they all were yeah the graduate
work was last summer that was 2019.
and how long did like the stuff from the
garage we work stay
in the uh um what would we call
the the treadmill room the treadmill
room oh well it wasn't the treadmill
room at the time
oh yeah it stayed in there until we
turned it into the treadmill room
oh you're right
yeah so that you know we made some
progress progress we got rid of like a
whole room's worth of stuff essentially
yeah
and we bought shelves so there's that i
would say um
what did we say six out of ten six out
of ten yeah that's fair
that's fair we've done okay
i think we'll we will um perhaps do a
podcast making goals again because i
think it's kind of interesting to look
back and see how we did um
i'll start brainstorming how different
do you think they're going to be from
2020 goals i don't know
well we'll think on it we'll think we'll
we'll put some time and
effort into like thinking what we
actually want you know hey
take more time to think and come up with
what we want to do yeah
we'll be accomplishing yeah some of our
20 20 goals by doing that yeah totally
to take
time and you know think about what we
want for 2021 there you go
okay now caitlyn caitlin prepared this
next section
yeah well i just thought it'd be a
little fun um
to you know since this is the year in
review to look at some
some interesting numbers um uh
basically we're just gonna brag on our
growth now i'm just kidding
um but no i i thought it'd be
interesting to share with you do you
remember
how big our channel was when january and
january 2020 because right now we are at
991k
subs were we at half a million we were
at 527k yeah
so pretty good pretty good guess so
we've gone up like 400 something
okay subs i'd say this is pretty good
yeah we should have written it down for
the game channel
we didn't double it but we
this is by far the most growth we've
ever had in the year yeah
yeah our biggest year biggest year yeah
it makes sense because like it's all
kind of like a
proportion of your total size you'd hope
so if things were healthy
you know to a certain point and then you
might like plateau plateaus yeah
yeah but very cool um our total views
on youtube right now we are at 104
million views which is kind of crazy
when we started the year is it half uh
half of that
500 million we were at 42 million
five 500 million would be five times
right
it's okay numbers are hard yeah numbers
are hard yeah okay
yeah so here's another here's so so
about proportional with the sub growth
about proportions yeah
um another thing i thought would be
interesting to look at would be this is
interesting this is interesting
so with the views i think that's that's
pretty cool because we've used more than
doubled our subs less than doubled yeah
the views more than doubled
and i think that's that's that's
interesting and that's what you'd hope
for because as we get more videos in our
backlog
the views will grow more and more too
because there's more videos for people
to watch
going back and everything yeah that's
neat
um i thought it would also be
interesting to look at our our the
changes in our twitch so right now we're
at 56
000 followers do you know what we were
at in january 2020 you want to guess
20k 10k oh wow
that's been like that's pretty big
that's really big it's like five times
the size
yeah that's really cool um and then our
total twitch views
right now do you know do you have any
idea no
i didn't really either 568 000 views huh
that's interesting i don't know how that
compares i have no idea
i literally have no idea how that
compares to like other channels that's
our total
views on twitch yeah in january we
started at 57k
views whoa so that's 10 10 times
yeah so even bigger than the followers
which is crazy
and then a very interesting thing evan
already knows this number yeah
i helped look this one up our right now
our average
viewership on twitch is 961 people it
sounds like live concurrent people
live concurrent with us at any given
moment yeah
and in january it was 147. that's so
that again that's like
a big big jump like twitch had very big
jumps even though the numbers aren't as
high as
youtube the like percentages were
pretty crazy yeah i think that we
figured out feel the change more there
yeah i feel like we we figured out a lot
in 2020
when it came to streaming and i think
i'm going to rearrange
some of the the uh outline that we have
in our google doc which we you know we
plan
these streams you know writing streams
or these
these uh podcasts um
but i'm gonna rearrange things because i
had a section for biggest
accomplishments highlight moments
turning points of 2020. okay yeah
and i think that the streaming things
were some of the biggest things that
changed
for me like the biggest like moments
in in our our year in a way and i think
it kind of started with the underwater
stream
yeah and diversifying what our streams
were
yeah because until then it had almost
almost exclusively just been gaming
yeah and we had been figuring out a lot
of things you know when we first started
streaming we just didn't know
much at all and we've been working on
this streaming setup and like all of the
the computers and cameras and we've
we've really really improved
um our setup and and all the back end
stuff like working with mods and like
setting up those systems in place you
know it's it's been a lot
to our mods thank you guys but it's been
interesting because like
i think that if we had of you know
pushed our twitch streams
you know and and gave you know and like
you know publicize it on our main
channel more
we wouldn't have been ready when we
first started streaming it's like we we
just
kind of like very quietly started yeah
very quietly started streaming and built
it up in an
organic way and everything we've been
streaming for like two years
yeah it's a long time because i still
like we joke about being noobs and stuff
and we
still often do feel like it because it
is like
you know youtube has always kind of been
the main job and twitch is like
the like side thing kind of yeah hobby
that's also part of our job
yeah but um yeah you know it's also
crazy
how much have i messed with this setup
in the past like two months a lot
okay oh in the past two months i thought
you were going to say since we started
yeah not much it's actually kind of
stabilized
no you've channeled all that energy to
the mobile streaming setup yeah the
mobile streaming setup yeah
and i think that was another thing that
you are um going to mention
as like some of our accomplishments
leading off of the underwater stream as
we started thinking a lot more about
other
non-gaming streams we can do we've done
a whole bunch of like
like i was going to say crafting streams
and a lot of them are crafting streams
but other stuff too like the crafting
streams the
pokemon stream the home designing stream
yeah the chillmas stream which was just
like so fun and cozy
honestly i think experiments i was going
to talk about the chillness stream
because
after like so okay let's explain what
the tillman stream was caitlyn do you
want to summarize it you're better at
that than me
uh we just hung out with our twitch
stream we decorated our christmas tree
we
um drank hot chocolate evan almost set
the house on fire
we wrapped presents honestly like after
we did that stream i was so happy
and i felt like so it felt so right
to do that stream and and you and i
talked about it
for a bit afterwards for a bit after the
stream but i don't think we ever like
talked about it elsewhere but i think
that that was just like
to me i i think we've really been like
finding our
stride when it comes to streaming and i
think the chillma stream was like a like
ah i really like this i want to channel
this energy and this
vibe in all of our streams and i know
that we can't have like
this every day chill this every day with
like wrapping presents and decorating a
tree and
having a fire pit and everything like
that but like i think it's more about
how do you
how how do you like
uh okay my words are hard right now but
i think one thing about the chilma
stream that
is the reason we had so much fun is it
kind of like it was a way to
concentrate our some of our favorite
vibes
about christmas and kind of concentrate
them
into an afternoon and really like
appreciate it
in a way that if we were just like
running on that work treadmill
we might not have you know um it's like
yeah we'd still put up the tree and we'd
still wrap presents but it might be like
here and there in the evenings when we
had time and we probably wouldn't take
the time to just sit down and enjoy hot
chocolate on the living room floor in
our pjs
yeah you know what i mean and so i think
that was one of the things that was so
special about it for us is it like
like gave us a reason to make a bigger
deal out of like christmasy stuff
yeah because we were sharing it with
other people too
and i feel like there are there could be
other like
things in life you know where you
you might not make it make a big enough
deal out of it yourself but if you think
about like sharing it with other people
maybe you find ways to like
make it more special and then it's even
more fun for you too yeah i mean like in
a way
our halloween streams yeah halloween
streams kind of like didn't really
save halloween for us but god it was
like the most halloweenish thing we did
because we our old tradition
was going to this haunted house in
austin every single year
obviously couldn't do that this year um
and we were kind of like
man what are we gonna what are we gonna
do like yeah and we can't do our thing
or have
anything any of the halloween things
that we would usually do
all of them weren't good to do yeah and
and doing our halloween streams like
doing our our makeup and doing the uh
we did um uh skeleton makeup live
and right after uh after taking a dinner
break then we did acrylic pours on
ceramic pumpkins yeah so both of those
were like really
not not just fun streams but like like
fun for us
but also like um i'm not sure important
to us
is the right word like
holidays that wouldn't have really been
like solidly
and i think that we'll you know we'll do
something for christmas and stuff coming
up but like
that like really i don't know i just
feel really good about it
and i still don't know how to apply it
going forward yeah
but it was it was really interesting
also for both of those streams
it was fun having like lots of things
lined up
like for for chill miss having like a
few events and a few things and
it's just it just gives me a lot to
think about for for future streams and
future content creation
um so i think those were impactful
moments for me what do you think
yes yeah do you have any do you have any
more were those like
in terms of streams what is in terms of
like other big moments of 2020 like
for me the things that stand out to me
the most are
a lot of the streams what about for you
um i mean
if you're saying biggest moments as in
like accomplishments and highlights
uh those would be some i think the
underwater stream was was one of the
biggest for me
um and some of the other stuff we've
already
talked about just kind of like pushing
ourselves more
with the content it's not like a single
moment really
it's just being more experimental with
projects that are cursed and not
practical at all
um uh
like not being afraid
to try out cooking videos even though it
was kind of like
an out of left field thing i don't know
there's not really like specific ones
for me
yeah i think it's kind of the overall i
did also write down our biggest videos
of 2020 just because i was kind of
oh like our most successful ones yeah so
number one
cat hamster wheel then mood ring toilet
seat and then tensegrity table
interesting yeah but you know what else
i would consider one of the biggest
videos even though it might not be up
there
in views yet is the transparent screen
because my guess is it's pretty close to
those ones but it came out super
recently
oh so i bet i think it might outgrow
them potentially really
maybe that's it just because it was that
was only like a month or so ago
yeah you know yeah so i don't know
i don't know do you want to talk about i
mean we don't want to like
harp on quarantine stuff in
like a negative way but it was a huge
part of 2020 and i thought it might be
interesting
to talk about how it affected us yeah a
little bit
i think one thing i added to this
section is what were some of our fails i
think one thing looking back quarantine
failures
like i didn't cut my hair for way too
long
and it got like weird like looking back
at some of the videos from this
from this year like caitlyn ended up
like you know giving me the cool fade we
probably need to like touch it up or
something
but like it ended up with my hair
looking better but i think
i think it's so interesting looking back
i just like didn't cut my hair for so
long
yeah i mean i still haven't cut my hair
but on my hair
since it's already so long you don't
notice the change as much
well you know what i think a lot of
people and i'm gonna maybe
project feelings that i have had before
but it's like
um when when it comes to your hair
if you're in a position where like
you've gone too long without cutting it
or you like can't really cut it or you
don't have time to cut it you get to a
certain point where you're like
well it's it's so grown out why don't i
just like let it keep going and see what
happens
this happened with me with like bangs
before like various things where it's
like
i'm already in the awkward phase what if
i just let it go a little bit longer and
then i'll just see
will it get less awkward it'll get less
awkward yeah
um and so i've seen a lot of people you
know like a lot of creators and stuff
letting the hair get kind of long and
crazy just to like see
and i think you just decided no
which it was probably best yeah
so what are some of the most unexpected
challenges of quarantine
um i think most
things like most of the challenges i
think are obvious and expected
like not seeing friends and family
and stuff like that i think one thing
that i missed
that i didn't expect to miss as much was
going to events
actually because we we used to go
to like every single maker event like
we said yes to everything we spoke at
events we would do like q and a
sessions and um you know at first
it was like every single one and then we
started
like declining a few just because like
you know like there's one that was super
fun to go to but it was overseas and we
just couldn't justify traveling and
you know we decided to slow down a
little bit and
um we were like yeah this is you know
for a while there was like one year
where we traveled every single month
either for an event or co-lab and it was
just too much so i thought like you know
maybe it'll be kind of nice to have an
excuse
not to go just so not that i didn't want
to go but it's just like
we had fomo saying no when we first
started saying no
to events and the fomo was really hard
so i was like
maybe it'll be kind of nice to have like
an excuse just so
that like we do have time to kind of
focus on like focus inwards because we
had spent so much time
like putting time outwards and i do
think that it was good
um and i did enjoy not feeling fomo
but i miss events even more than i
expected like i expected
like i would love to go to like a couple
a year i think that would be great you
know much better than like the five
or six years of like things we were
doing for a little bit there
um but i i
miss it a lot and we were really excited
about going to
like we were hoping to go to vidcon and
twitchcon this year before everything
happened and
we've never been to either of those and
not being able to go was like dang
and i just didn't you know because we
had
been pulling back i hadn't expected that
to be
like as big of a bummer
yeah yeah yeah what about you was there
any like unexpected things
obviously i think related to that
interestingly like hanging out
with our live audience on twitch
kind of like is a part of that you know
like
some of the audience part of that
because we do get to like interact with
people live and there's something
that's true kind of cool about that yeah
and
and like you know we we get to know our
social interaction
i say that live but we're not joking
like you guys
are our social interaction and i think
that that related to that like you know
we also really like hanging out with
content creators and you know like just
talking behind the scenes stuff with
other people who know the
behind-the-scenes stuff
and i think it's been interesting like
we haven't made many connections on the
streaming side
but it's also interesting we have made
some connections on the streaming
content creator side and it's been
interesting like
you know making videos with other people
and like chatting behind the scenes with
them and stuff so it's like
you know i know a lot of people have
turned to
online versions of
you know social interactions like social
interactions or substitutes for things
that are in their life but online i
think we did that some with
with uh streaming yeah um
other unexpected challenges you know
it's like it's not a challenge but
you know you're talking about things
that you miss i would really like to go
out on a date with you
i really want to go on a date so much
and i think that one of the
like unexpected challenges is like since
we work from home and since our entire
house is
work every room pretty much has some
element
of work in it like all the rooms where
we spend time in
yeah there's some like memory of like
work and i think that one of the
unexpected challenges is
when we would socialize more when we
would go out on dates when we would like
leave our house often it was like going
out to eat something yeah
those were the times where we left work
behind yeah
and it's been much harder to leave work
behind
when you don't leave the house
you don't leave the house we haven't
really come up with a strategy
and i think that that's one thing that i
didn't realize
before we didn't leave the house like
that was our non-work time
yeah yeah that is interesting and we
haven't really
fixed that not really not really
yeah there's just something about like
being
a wave yeah for us in particular
you know because like i know that like
you know like
if one of us is prepping work like the
other one of us is usually like
working one of prepping a meal
one of us is usually like you know
launching a video or answering comments
or
one of us is doing work stuff so it's
like
not a long enough time for us to leave
work mode
and enjoy non-work mode
properly yeah well because also if you
think about like
the time it takes you to actually eat
yes isn't that long
you know a lot of like going to a
restaurant is like you drive there you
wait to be seated
you're seated and you're waiting a
little bit you have your meal
you wait for the check like you like
drive home
or sometimes we would like go on a walk
after dinner depending on where we were
eating
we'd like walk around the area um and so
it's like a whole
like it takes up a larger chunk of time
so it is more of an escape than when
like
um you know cooking and cleaning up
takes up
time but like those aren't things that
we typically do together just because
it's less efficient it's more efficient
for one person to
like go back to start working on stuff
and the other person to like clean up
and intent
is like finish off work as fast as you
can so that we can have time together
not working but we just kind of end up
working a lot
so i think that to me that's the biggest
challenge unexpected challenge of
quarantine
like having a harder time escaping work
and just working
so much um not not to like
bright what's it called like i think
that like some people are calling like
bright siding things like
putting a positive spin on something
that isn't that positive
is that what's called bright siding that
sounds familiar i think that's a slaying
word that's popping up in 2020.
i could see that yeah with all the i
don't know i don't know if that's the
right word if i'm using it right but not
to like bright side 2020
it's like looking just the two of us
are there any good things that came from
quarantining and
and all of that that we might want to
carry forward
um i mean this isn't
really like in our personal life there's
more in our work life but i think
like going back to streaming
being quarantined i think made me
appreciate streaming even more
and like that fun interaction and stuff
you know and i do think we'll carry that
forward
um there are things that i like
it's all kind of like silly stuff um
that i that we that we did differently
during quarantine that i think we might
continue
like a curbside grocery store pick up
you know what i mean i'm like oh you
know
that's pretty nice maybe i'll continue
doing curbside groceries or pick up
or like um there's
this is like so like such dumb examples
but like because
we stopped eating out and we would take
food home we've
developed something interesting yeah
we've optimized the way that we do that
so like one example
is um we enjoy in and out
and although we love their burgers we
weren't like
super big fans of the fries like the
fries are fine but they're nothing crazy
but because we take food home now
when we get in and out then we go to
mcdonald's and get mcdonald's fries
because that's a premium combo right
there you know what i mean
i foresee us continuing to do that after
quarantine and taking that food home
so that we can drive through two
different places for one single meal so
it's kind of like
we have very specific requirements now
for that so it's kind of like the
shake-up made us like re-evaluate
certain things and optimize them even
more yeah yeah
i don't know it's um you know i also
hope this doesn't really affect us but i
i hope like in the world there is more
flexibility on like being able to work
from home when you need to
and things like that you know yeah um
also i think that that it's it's
interesting
like i think the the big
reason a lot of people gave for not
being able to work from home is like oh
you won't be effective
the company won't won't work and it's
been proven that it will
yeah so i hope that that continues to be
an option for people
that you know need to work from home or
maybe they work better from home
yeah yeah i mean it's definitely not for
everyone i know some people really
maybe haven't liked it but i'm sure that
some people have or even like
or maybe like you just want to do it one
day a week you know it's it's different
like
having to do it every single day yeah
that there's definitely downsides to
that but if maybe you just want to be
able to do it every friday
you know yeah i don't know i just think
i i hope that
flexibility in that department remains
yeah
okay so katelyn what are some things
that you thought would do in quarantine
that we didn't
um i'm the one that put this question
down i but i don't really have an answer
i was gonna ask you do you have any
thoughts
i mean there's like goals hey this is
one thing that everyone thought they do
more
during quarantine play video games
and technically we've played more
video games technically technically we
have
i'm actually going to pull up our
analytics i want to see like
how many hours of games we've streamed
did we stream more in 2020
oh i'm pretty sure okay starting
starting in february
we did do more march we did even more
april was the most we've ever you know
streamed and game and then it fell
back down to about average by july and
it's been kind of
average since so but there was there
certainly was like a moment
where we really did stream and game a
lot more but even when that fell a
little bit it was still on average
higher
than 2019 yeah you're right sure yeah
you're right like
double or triple yeah more consistent
and
like a little bit higher and stuff so
hey we played for video games
and we made content yeah
yeah um honestly i just expected us i
was like well we work from home
before we work from home now we'll
probably just work
even more because we won't be seeing
people
and kind of true you know
did i have any expectations going into
quarantine
maybe that would cook more oh we
certainly didn't
we did for the first like few weeks it
just takes so much time
well there was also like especially when
it was like
first officially quarantined like state
home orders and all that stuff
like we were really nervous about even
like going through drive-throughs
you know it was just like everything was
all
new and unknown and so there was like a
few weeks where we literally didn't
leave the house for everything
i like like
i had like one big grocery trip where i
bought enough to make like
lots of frozen meals that we could cook
like big batches of and we didn't leave
for like three weeks
we spent like days prepping and cooking
and so much all that
so much time cooking hey we benefited
from it first we did we've been eating
that stuff
long after that you know like we are all
about that prepping and freezing and
benefiting from that past work usually i
spread it out instead of doing it all
in like one weekend yeah um
yeah we we eat out more than i expected
like i almost feel like we eat out more
now
even though we're not going to
restaurants i don't know maybe just
because like
it doesn't feel worth just like running
to the grocery store
and even though like obviously i wear a
mask and all for like a single
like me alert yeah it just doesn't feel
worth it to just like go for a few
supplies so i like to let the list build
up a little bit more and
now i'm you know lately i'm doing
curbside
um but you know i still would feel bad
having like two crips i'd pick up for
like two items so i let the list build
up more yeah
in between shopping trips that's
interesting so katelyn looking back
summarizing 2020 did 2020 defeat us
or did it just make us stronger i don't
think it defeated us
i mean there's definitely discouraging
parts about it yeah
um did it make us stronger i don't know
about that either but
i i mean i i feel like we are stronger
and we've improved over the course of
the year but i don't think i can like
attribute that to that i attribute it to
2020. but we didn't let it
hold us back we didn't want to hold us
back we kept on pushing our contact
we kept on expanding into streaming we
kept on like
you know str staying true to like what
we wanted
from our life and we made it happen and
even though we didn't get perfect scores
on all of the 2020 goals we set for
ourselves
they weren't because of the year that
2020 was
no you know what i mean yeah and i think
that we like did
okay with our goals who hits all of
their goals 100
nobody nobody we're we're humans we're
not perfect we got a couple nine out of
ten
we've got a couple nine out of ten yeah
we'll just you know the three out of
tens we'll just put those back on the
the goal list and continue to try for
next year
all right sounds good it is time for the
thing of the week
[Music]
all right so my thing of the week is um
the 2020 artist rewind for those of you
guys who might not know um
every year starting in like 2013 or 2014
youtube would do a big youtube rewind
where they look back on the year
and everything that happened the past
couple have been pretty universally
hated although i will say that 2018 was
kind of so bad it was good
yeah in a way like it was so memeable
2019 2019 was just like a listicle
and it was disappointing in 2020 they
decided not to do it
um and so there's been lots of
creators in the community who have
talked about doing
their own and we were actually a part of
one so
nerdy crafter uh jackie is her name um
got together and gathered a bunch of
like crafting and art communities
to do or art crafting and art creators
to do like an art
community 2020 rewind and it was super
fun to be a part of it
yeah um i think if you just if you go to
the nerdy crafter channel or if you just
search
2020 artist rewind it'll pop up
um but it's it's very wholesome you'll
if you watch our channel you'll probably
recognize some other faces in there too
if you like our type of content
um but this is very wholesome it gives
you all these good feelings that was
nice it was cute
yeah it was really cute um it's been a
little bit since it came out i think
this is our first podcast since it came
out so we wanted to
give it a shout out here um but it's so
cute
jackie did such a great job coordinating
with so many different creators but also
it hit the right vibe it had that like
old school youtube rewind
yeah feel uh you know
um but yeah it was just you know she hit
some trends like
it was just it's just great yeah it was
one week ago
is when it went live we just we just
pulled it up to look at it but super
cute
um we'll have a link to it in the
description caitlyn what's your thing of
the week
another video to recommend um so
uh we were sent a custom soap by
cat and raven designs so cute so cute
and they made a video
where they made the soap and there's
just so much thought
and like ian k lore put into it it was
like a galaxy
geode jube soap yeah they like molded a
little tiny jube
but even like the wrapping it has like
our like you know floating in space on
there
the wrapping was custom um so we'll have
a link to it uh
it's just like a like fun cute little
video you hear them like bantering and
they did challenge us through cool
process
i know it's in our future we we will you
you
will know that we'll eventually do it we
got a little distracted with candles
yeah yeah yeah it would be nice to do it
with someone who
who who uh has a little bit more
experience but
that's not possible oh in person no i
think we're just gonna have to figure it
out
we're doing it live they said if we can
do resin we can do cold process soap
okay maybe we'll start with like a basic
one
i think the main thing that i'm worried
about is like doing
something because like i think i think i
haven't really fully
processed it and said this out loud cold
process
but i think this is the reason why i
have a hesitation
and i think that our videos this year
have have
allowed me to kind of like move past
this hesitation
i think that in the past
i always want to like
do an impressive version of that thing
so it's like
if we are woodworking we want to do like
woodworking but with a cool twist
or like you know what have you but i
think that like and i think that my main
reasons
my main hesitation for like not doing
cold process soap
is because i would want to do something
like a jube themed
resin galaxy geode and like you know in
that they
did like soap clay and they did like a
whole bunch of different colors and they
did swirls
and they did like a there's so much
going on they squeezed a bag and molded
things on top and they did mix-ins and
all this stuff
our first cold process soap is probably
going to be kind of basic
i think and i think that that's like
more okay with that now
i'm a lot more okay with just saying
like we're trying cold process out for
the first time and that's what it is
instead of saying like geode rainbow
galaxy
cold process soap and i think that was
my main hesitation
before and i think that it's okay to
just like say like hey this is like
us documenting our very first cold
process soap
is it gonna explode or will it harden
and heat too fast
in the bowl yeah you know and i think
that like yeah we were trying to do too
much
or the ideas we had were always too much
the ideas we had are always too much
as our first attempt i think i'm more
okay with it just being
about our first time and that's enough i
think the candle making video
had played a role in that shift of
feeling now the candle
making was a like it wasn't this first
that there was a stick maybe we can
still come up with like a tiny stick
it's interesting thinking about our
first melt and pour soap because we were
like
we kind of had the same thing because
we're like well we need to like
experiment and learn this stuff
uh but like doing something fancy seems
kind of overwhelming we'll just do 37.
30 seconds all sorts of different like
mixing things
there's a lot of them yeah so maybe
we'll we'll come up with like
uh yeah good enough minor stick
so that we feel comfortable releasing it
but not so much mistake that we feel
intimidated to take it on
yeah i think it's a good good goal 2021
goal
no that's fair that's for another
podcast all right guys also
we have been keeping track of all of the
reviews that you guys have been sending
in
for the podcast they they make our day
they make us really happy
it's so nice seeing that five-star
review
on whatever podcast app you guys are
listening to
we are continuing the prank i think that
i actually
like saw a review on there saying they
didn't know what our podcast was
the prank worked yeah and caitlin what
was like our rank
in in in the podcast app we were like
number 11 in lifestyle or something
crazy in some country at least
like in canada or something i don't know
what it was we're making our way up
there in the charts guys the prank is
working
it's working i see it working and it's
it's really fun so if you guys
don't know what the prank is we're
asking you guys to leave a five-star
review on whatever app
and then eventually someone's going to
like find our podcast and we don't
know about our youtube channel and
they're going to be so confused so
confused
so if you guys would continue that
that'd be really fun
um in the meantime i hope you're having
a wonderful day um happy birthday if
it's your birthday
and we'll see you in the next content
bye guys
bye i really like the shift to next
content
yes it's good it's accurate
you